Uh,
what does somebody mean when they refer to the converse inverse or
contrapositive of a statement he could simple statement about,
um,
no,
not that.
No.
Wait,
back to,
ah,
I like that one.
Bikes have two wheels,
logical thinkers that you and I are,
we can see that this means everything that's a bike has two wheels.
The logical structure is for all x.
X is a bike implies x has two wheels.
Let's write that symbolically.
That's first order logic,
but we can just simplify that even further with the two propositions.
If you got a blank look on your face or your eyes are glazing over right now,
go back and check out my logic and language series.
You can play with that statement first.
Inverted the inverse of if it's a bike,
then it has two wheels is if it's not a bike than it does not have two wheels.
The inverse of a statement isn't necessarily true in this case.
There are two wheeled objects that are not bikes.
The converse of if it's a bike than it has two wheels switches the terms.
So we ended up with if it has two wheels than it's a bike.
The converse may be true if the original is true,
but it isn't necessarily,
but notice that the converse will be true with the inverse is true.
Think about that.
The inverse negated.
Both propositions and the converse switched both propositions.
There's also a contrapositive with switching and negation going on for our
original statement.
If it's a bike,
then it has two wheels.
The contrapositive is if it's not two wheeled Ben,
it's not a bike.
Looks like that's true.
So long as the original was.
It's not good logic.
If we can't abstract these structures to other instances using any two
propositions,
a and B,
where a implies B,
we can get to the inverse,
the converse and the contrapositive this way.
Something
to notice if you want to get even more playful with your logic is that you can
use the concepts recursively on themselves.
What I mean is,
for example,
the inverse isn't just the universe of the statement.
It's also the converse of the contrapositive because it switches the two
propositions around and the contrapositive isn't just the contrapositive.
It's also the converse of the inverse.
This is possible because every statement can be reevaluated just like the
original.
They're not inherently in versus or converses or contrapositive.
They're just statements.
They're those things in relation to each other.
You'll find that people fumble with these terms or use them in precisely.
So take this first step to straighten out for yourself.
The relationship between a statement and the ways it can be twisted up.